what's up check it out check it out and
stuff it's
congratulations crazy
dude it is episode
186 i think maybe unless we
change the order which we might
because we do we want hell yeah dude
don't like it when i have plastic water
bottles on here because then people
think i'm being bad to the ocean
when in actuality i love the ocean i
love the ocean so much
i don't get in there and piss in it uh
and i don't get in there period pretty
much because the ocean is for
basically marine biology and sharks and
stuff
and not me dude did you know that well
now you do
[Music]
let's start with a disrespectful drink
which you know means
respectful and let's just get into it
dude
[Music]
previously on congratulations
dude abc chime
[Laughter]
we added it to the soundboard baby yeah
dude that's [ __ ] amazing it makes me
feel
[Applause]
so um you know i'm not gonna lean on the
sound board you know what i mean
but i'm gonna have a little bit of fun
with it every now and then i'm gonna pop
in and i'm gonna pray some [ __ ]
and then i'm gonna [ __ ] sit back and
relax and just talk a little bit but um
it is what it is and you know what dude
uh
i i you know it's cool it's hot in here
so that's great
it's almost a sauna the background looks
like a sauna by the way every podcast
has this now so that's great
yay we want it to be original and then
every podcast got dizzy yay dude
that's [ __ ] amazing man that's so
cool everybody
everybody's got this and i and [ __ ]
there's literally nine nine [ __ ]
comedy podcasts
they got this like okay
that's fine i don't give a [ __ ] i really
don't but i just want to point it out
if i did it and someone else had done it
already
people would be like that delia
[ __ ] he's biting and i'd have to
be like
nah i don't think so
um because who gives a [ __ ] what the
wall looks like but they're doing it
that's all i'm saying is that they're
doing it
um so yeah so i ordered food
it'll be on its way it's on its way and
it'll show up when it shows up
and that's when i'll have to [ __ ]
make a slice in the editing [ __ ] and
then
have to get the food so that's what's up
and maybe i won't
but uh maybe it won't get here because
it's postmates and postmates sometimes
comes and sometimes it rings the
doorbell and sometimes it it says
ring the doorbell when it's instructed
not to ring the doorbell and sometimes
it it [ __ ]
it doesn't give you option for priority
and then it makes all sorts of different
trips before it even gets to your
[ __ ] house and the time you get
you're eating a chicken sandwich
and it's colder than a [ __ ] polar
bear's toenail dude
like uh what's his name said on outcast
um yeah so
that's i you know how's it been how's it
been well you know it's been no it's
been okay
um just got out of my group therapy so
feeling a little bit good that always
makes me feel
feel good um and
uh i i i honestly wanted to start with
something i can't remember what it is
but that's what this [ __ ]
podcast is all about dude it's about
not having a [ __ ] you know these guys
will be like so what are we going to
talk about today like there's some late
night show host and that's i'm not that
dude
have you seen by the way late show in
the pandemic
what what are they doing hey guys just
wait until everything comes back they're
doing like bits in the bathtub and [ __ ]
stephen colbert will be like in a
bathtub and just be like oh hey guys
didn't see you there
and i love stephen colbert but i'm just
still like oh
wow why are you doing that in the tub
dude
um so yeah
i'm but yeah that's what's going on but
i was gonna say something dude
how about the [ __ ] how about uh sign
up for our patreon that's
that's what i was gonna say sign up for
our patreon uh patreon.comcrystallia you
get the raw
uncut congratulations episodes you get
one episode uh extra a month
and you get all sorts of extra bonus
content you know um
so that's great and live it up
live it up baby live it up dude
beep
remember the [ __ ] misa unlimited that
was the thing that happened what's that
guy's name
russell wilson could be a limited dude
i'm gonna [ __ ] play this clip this
was one of the things that happened
while i was on my hiatus where i was
like
oh for [ __ ] sake dude this
[ __ ] had to do this while i was
on hiatus
mr unlimited a lot of you guys probably
know what it is dude
but dude it is so amazing
for some reason i keep thinking it goes
unlimited let's see if
my memory serves me correctly mr
unlimited typing this into [ __ ]
um youtube and it comes up i type mr u
and it comes up and mr russell wilson
russell wilson is one of those names i
can't [ __ ] say russell wilson i got
to say it quick
russell wilson okay unlimited
dude first of all that's just the
middle of it mr unlimited yeah
you gotta be unlimited you gotta have a
thought process of being unlimited said
absolutely nothing dude
ten seconds of [ __ ] absolutely saying
nothing and that's the most amazing
thing that you can do is be talking but
not saying anything and that's what this
podcast
is all about um can you find just the
regular clip of it
where it's just the whole thing because
the whole lead up into it is amazing
the whole thing's like three minutes and
he can't even [ __ ] and he's saying
nothing and it's also the most [ __ ]
scentsy thing i've ever heard in my life
it's the most [ __ ] s insecure thing
i've ever heard in my life
it's insecure it's scentsy he's
basically from cincinnati dude
i can't even believe how insecure it is
to be like
[Laughter]
sneezing dude sneezing while he says it
huh oh limited sneezing we're gonna find
it did we find it yet no
i that's what i hate about [ __ ]
youtube dude you gotta type it in and
it's like oh here it is and then you
play it
and then it's like so russell wilson did
a [ __ ] thing and check it out yeah
he's the king of cringe here on extra
points
you found it are you sending it how are
you sending it to me
at the top of the all right here we go
it's at the top man baby
it's at the top my baby um
and i can't find it on my [ __ ] thing
hey yeah dude here we go it's at the top
here we go
oh yeah that's right he [ __ ] tweeted
it here we go
hey guys uh russell here yes the typical
boring yes russell the
robot russell the one you guys love to
know humming so much
that's typical boring yes russell yes an
evil villain a [ __ ]
evil villain dude unlimited dude
i love how there's a [ __ ] chick in
the background in the mirror too like
what is she thinking dude let's break
this video down
hey guys uh russell here yes the typical
boring oh the [ __ ] blase
attitude that he went into this with is
only something
mr unlimited could do that's russell
the robot russell the one you guys love
to know are real real
exciting you know i'm really excited um
but anyways uh
everybody has to have an alter ego ran
out of breath and i've been thinking
about
it for no reason ran out of breath uh
everybody has to have
ran out of breath for no reason how
about to have in the in the [ __ ]
middle of having breath
ran out of breath unbelievable um but
anyways how about how about you know
he's not unlimited about [ __ ]
breath uh everybody you know
here we go have an alter ego right no
they don't i've been thinking about what
i'd be so nervous anyways uh everybody
has to have an alter ego right and
i've been thinking about one minute you
know how you could tell someone is so
[ __ ] from cincinnati when they've
when they're talking is when they open
their mouth for way too long before they
say something
and he does it right here ultra ego
right and
i've been thinking about what my alter
ego would be and here wait hold on
where's
everybody has to have an alter ego no no
no no here's right here you guys love to
know
a real real exciting you know i'm real
excited um but anyways
uh everybody right there but everybody
has to
have an alter ego right and i've been
thinking about what my alter ego would
probably
i think i have an alter ego his name his
name's
the payoff dude it better be good you
know what i mean
his name better be like my alter ego is
dick sucker jones
do you know what i'm saying the
bombastic [ __ ] chaser
but this guy just says her ego
his name his name's mr mr mr
unlimited yeah you gotta be unlimited
you
gotta have a thought process of being
unlimited so when people ask you
you know what you're thinking about or
what you wanna do in life or where you
wanna go
you gotta be unlimited tell them i'm
unlimited you know what i mean so when
they ask you certain questions like
who brings your motivation russell oh i
got his wife involved now
i see certain questions like who brings
you motivation
there was a [ __ ] pause like it was on
the news we're going live with
the [ __ ] to [ __ ] guy guyerson and
uh he's there live at the scene here we
go what do you think guy
hi uh that's that's how the girl was and
she's right there she's not certain
questions like who brings your
motivation
russell mr unlimited
who who is your role model rather shrug
unlimited what who's your go-to
person for advice russell they think
pete carroll they think this person
thinks that person well i love you pete
but
it's mr unlimited tom
wow ended it too soon dude
i love how he says they think it's who
who they say
new person for advice russell they think
p carol they think this person think
that person
didn't come up come up with three people
you know totally [ __ ] not unlimited
with how many names you could think of
totally limited with how many names you
get
they think pete wilson they think um
well turns out i'm limited thinking the
names
but this person that person you know
unlimited dude when i saw that that's it
i got that video was so [ __ ]
unbelievable to me when i saw that i got
shorter that's how [ __ ] badass that
video was
hey guys uh russell here yes the typical
boring yes yes yes
robot robot guys love to know real real
exciting
i'm really excited um anyways i love it
dude everybody has that i love this he
i love what videos where guys are
walking around their house and you get
to see how [ __ ] dope their house is
you
ever see that p diddy one where he's
like he's like talking he's walking
so for so long i i there's no way i'll
be able to push it
pull it up but dude he's just like
talking and it's like a minute long
instagram
and you're like is he at the [ __ ]
four seasons and then he's just like at
his house
pee diddy you know talk about mercer
[Music]
and yes that that russia is boring at
robot runs like that
he says like my old [ __ ] uh you know
my manager you know i'm just
literally look look mr unlimited in
there you know
um
now like you know he's unlimited okay
look you think about
russell wilson okay and look yeah yeah
sorry he's got a
limit so i think he's unlimited
okay um but man
my god dude mr unlimited
[ __ ] that bro i'm mr limited
okay you're limited i don't like that
whole thing that whole vibe
that whole like no fear i'm mr unlimited
you can do anything you put your mind to
mind to
what about dying you know what about
giving up what about giving up sometimes
what about knowing your limit so you
don't die
what about that you ever go on a walk
and you're like
oh [ __ ] i should have brought water
and you turned back
that's the [ __ ] you know what i'm you
know
what do you what do you put gas in your
car you literally put gas in your car
and when it runs out you put more gas in
your car
you don't drive the [ __ ] and
you're like let's see what happens you
[ __ ] your car up
if your car's not mr unlimited you're
not mr unlimited your body
is a machine
don't do things like climb the [ __ ]
mount everest everyone's got to do some
[ __ ] to
prove they're a real person you know
oh i want to watch this dude this is the
greatest
i've came across this somebody on the
discord if you're on my patreon you sign
up for the highest tier you can get on
the discord
and uh you can pitch me segments
somebody's pitched me this segment
i don't know who it is that sucks i need
to start remembering their name so i
could shout him out thank you whoever
did this
this is called snipes rap battle verses
i don't know
i guess this is just you have to put the
words in the sentence
but uh snipes rap
battle verses i'm sorry this is the
worst freestyle well it's not even that
but in a way it's the illest and you
know what
i've decided this is the greatest
freestyle i've ever heard in my life and
let me tell you why
this guy knew he came with nothing and
didn't give a [ __ ] and
still did it that's my hero do you
understand
this guy wanted to get by with
pure him
that's the best i'm going to
neil that's him neil mickey d
oh neil mickey d shared this on my
discord thanks neil mickey d
change it here it is i'm sorry little
kids
but i'mma kill a clown today ah so
from new jersey i'm a killer clown today
sorry little kids but i'm a cl i'm
a killer clown today so
[ __ ] essex new jersey
little kids but i'm gonna kill a clown
today oh man that guy's my cousin
say bullets are going to spray i'm from
brooklyn so
[ __ ] absolutely is it lackadaisical
is that the word
lacks back a days ago so [ __ ]
lackadaisical dude
sorry my bullets are going to spray an
accountant dude
i'm sorry little kid wow the fact that
the guy
had so much faith in him before he went
that he goes get it
how [ __ ] stupid is rhyming in a
circle
i'm sorry little kids but i'm a killer
clown today i could say bullets are
gonna spray
i'm from brooklyn that's all right but
let me just say i like to get close and
personal
with a razor sharp object oh he's
british but
let me just say this so far saying a lot
of stuff
and prefacing it with let me just say
love that i'm sorry little kids
but i'mma kill a clown today i could say
bullets are gonna spray i'm from
brooklyn
that's all right oh he's from brooklyn
let me just bring it i like to get close
and personal so confusing already
so confusing already bullets are going
to spray i'm from brooklyn that's okay
let me just say i'm british too object
but
let me just say this okay i'm not going
to stab you in the heart oh thank you
what i'm going to do is grab a pen
stab you in the neck punch your lungs
slam
a blunt object into your stomach
[ __ ] completely [ __ ] off the rails
already and
it is [ __ ] 26 seconds in
on [ __ ] believable this guy
got to a point in his rap battle career
that he thought he could enter this
cipher
and fail so miserably
26 26 seconds dude i could rap for 26
seconds better than this
and and i'll do it afterwards okay
object into your stomach
and cause internal bleeding oh so
[ __ ] specific
a doctor do it and cause internal
bleeding
now before you die let me just say this
okay
okay so he's he's very graphic he hit it
he stabbed you in the neck with a pen
and bludgeoned something else in his
stomach and then uh
did it somehow else right can't remember
what it was but he did a lot of a lot of
bad stuff at causing internal bleeding
now before you die let me just say this
so this is gonna be a banger this is
gonna be the punch line right this is
where everyone's gonna go
oh myself synopsis because i take my
time okay here we go
the reason i call myself snipes is
because i take my time to rhyme i'm not
complicated
but well we know the reason
i call myself snipes is because i take
my time to write i'm not complicated
imagine a guy telling you that before
you die
oh what he [ __ ]
stabbed you in the neck bludging you in
the [ __ ] internal bleeding you're
dying
doing it coughing up blood and he's like
i just want you to know the reason why i
call
they call me snipes is because i don't
i'll take my time to write
i'm not complicated
i'm like a sniper i aim straight for the
heart or the head
i'm straight and direct i might hide 2ks
that way
you'll know when i hit you oh wow as
soon as you hit the ground
the dog the dog
crying dude the dog is even like where's
this [ __ ]
get the ball you know when i hit you as
soon as you hit the ground
but this guy said some [ __ ] on facebook
here we go joker the dark knight [ __ ] so
don't let me go all james homes on you
dark knight shooter is that a little bit
too soon
it's too soon to be wrapping in a cipher
um say this as well
if you want to be the joker why don't i
give you a bottle of pills a chelsea
smile
and instead of heath ledger dying why
don't you replace his
death oh
that is the [ __ ] hardest that is the
hardest rap bar i've ever heard in la in
my life
dude oh you want to be the joker well
how about this instead of heath ledger
dying
why don't you take his death
oh that's so hard dude this guy's [ __ ]
this guy
has bars dude instead of he threatens to
die why don't you
replace his death as well
if you want to be the joker why don't i
give you a bottle of pills a chelsea
smile
and instead of heath ledger dying why
don't you replace his
death
that's so hard i gave you a [ __ ]
runner dude that is so hard i gave you a
runner
i mean that's the hardest rap lyric i
ever [ __ ] heard in my life all right
here we go moving on nobody would give
two shits
about a guy who looks like a [ __ ]
meth head
wow so raw
you said in your first battle against
just talking just talking that
his face looks like he got into a fight
just
talking and recycling [ __ ] your face
looks like you got into a fight with the
blunt side of an axe okay
says face so many times
pausing for so long
still pausing they cut they literally
think that i'm a soft cop
really i couldn't give two [ __ ] because
you don't know me you don't know what
i'm so defensive
ricky gervais in the office yeah this is
rap battling i'm gonna give to fox
only for the factor of i do this because
i love it whether or not i chose
what dude you're talking
he loved what oh is the [ __ ]
postmates here
oh yeah
dude that is so [ __ ] funny it doesn't
matter
he rhymed once uh once he runs once so
far i think but
at one ounce if there's
who basically their [ __ ] just bricks
like indian curry the after effects
so offensive and so offensive
go do something else don't do something
with your life we should make a law if
two shares
a kid ever have a kid get his dick in a
[ __ ] all right we should shoot the
little kid
so crass i'm so violent dude he's coming
around
dick in a con and like a kid shoot the
little kid so
the most awful thing i've ever heard in
my life like headless [ __ ] chickens a
waste of space
wow but oh so some guy goes damn
he was feeling it that guy i want to
know i want to interview that guy
but damn i'm gonna say this maybe next
time
i'll come repeat prepared i got [ __ ]
up last night i forgot my lines
memorize them don't know where the [ __ ]
i put the piece of paper in my house
admitting it
next time i'm not gonna [ __ ] up i'm
gonna memorize my lines
and i just forgot the piece of paper i
forgot to bring the piece of paper from
brooklyn
that's real i bet you after this battle
i'm gonna go home
just be wandering around having a ciggy
and then i'm just going to find him and
be like oh [ __ ] no there they are just
talking
the that guy's my favorite rapper of all
time
great congratulations thank you very
much you have
duh you are dubbed congratulations
greatest rapper of all time
that is unbelievable dude
i'm surprised you didn't say hi i just
want to say one more thing do you know
who i am right now
um this other video makes me [ __ ]
laugh
dude i can't believe i've never talked
yeah you know we had a few odd man
rushes there in the first period which
was uh
this i love when guys just don't know
what they're doing
this guy's never been on camera before
you know and he's it must be he
mark sending i guess this must be like
his first time being interviewed because
when he sees it this guy's gonna be like
oh no um yeah you know we had a few
odd man rushes there in the first period
which was uh not good for us but i mean
everyone had their nerves going and
everything like that and then
which we were glad to just keep them to
one and everything like that and then we
went back and
after the period in the locker room just
talked about what we need to fix and
everything like that
stick to the game plan get back on it
and everything like that so
just paid off stick to the game plan you
know stiffen up defense and everything
like that
no pinches everything like that
your uncle stu played here oh it still
goes it's
did you get any advice from him coming
in here to the tournament um yeah i got
a nice
long text from him this morning saying
uh don't let the atmosphere uh
you know get your nerve shaken up and
everything like that just oh so that's
where he gets it from his [ __ ] uncle
if he does that in the text that's seven
player game
which is what i tried to do out here and
everything like that so
yeah the even the guys from home and
everything like that oh the semifinals
you get still water your initial
thoughts on the big matchup
everything like that game i can't wait
to play them i know they're doing good
only one loss on the season i believe
and everything like that and
dude he hit 10 and everything like that
in um yeah how many minutes dude
in one minute dude
in one minute he hit 10 and everything
like that
in one minute that's one and everything
like every seven seconds or so
six seconds six seconds right every six
seconds
dude he's good at math oh he only got it
[ __ ] wrong once and then got it right
[ __ ] yeah you know what happened one
dude um
actually should i even tell this on the
on the podcast yeah okay
so um my uh my fiance she's do
taking classes because she she she's
going back to school and [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah dude that that rips dude
going back to school and uh she uh
and she's retaking some classes and she
couldn't [ __ ] figure out the answer
for a math problem and i [ __ ] helped
and i did it dude and i said go away i'm
gonna get this
and i [ __ ] did it and i got it and
the answer was one bit there were two
two parties sir it was one billion at
880 million was the second part
dude and i got it right i put my mind to
it and it took 43 minutes for me to get
the right answer
and i [ __ ] got it dude i got it and
it was about
what was it about like treasury bonds or
some [ __ ] dude and i got it right your
boy got it right your boy got it right
and it was about treasury bonds dude oh
you thought he was a comedian
but in actuality he could do math and it
only takes 45 minutes
hell yeah dude mathematical renter
that's so
ill that i did that you could put your
mind to it and everything like that
and do it and everything like that you
can't put your mind into any you can't
do anything you put your mind to but
dude i was looking at equations i was
googling stuff
hell yeah
isn't that cool i'm cool
[Music]
um
uh sometimes you got to do stuff
in relationships like you know you don't
have to necessarily do
school work if you don't want to but
um she was like let's have friends over
and i was like
fine you know
when you decide to have friends over and
it's just like then it's like a whole
thing and then
you like you make plants she's like i'm
like when she's like monday and i'm and
it's like
wednesday and you're like i gotta make
plans [ __ ]
five six days in a row who knows what
crystalia i'm gonna be by then
who do you want to invite over and she
goes a couple i know
and a couple that you know and i'm like
they don't even know
they don't even know each other we're
all gonna have to be like
yeah and yeah oh yeah well you don't and
you
you know you did that didn't you do a
similar
thing with you because you were in but
you were around that area right so
you guys
i think they're getting along good
luckily we've got great friends and
stuff so everybody was on page one
immediately they came over everyone was
on page one
friggin immediately now we're laughing
we're having a good time
we're eating food we ordered italian
you know and we're having a good time
eating it and [ __ ]
my friend brought over his dog and the
dog literally [ __ ]
in calvin's play area pissed on the
kitchen table
in the hallway in the bedroom and tore
up two slippers
from different pairs don't bring it
again
okay so uh
we're laughing having a good time and
then
like kristen brings out a [ __ ] game
and i'm just like no she brings out like
five games
like she's like she's where's waldo with
the games
like just toppling over and [ __ ]
just holding him like this and then
[ __ ] puts them down and she's like
which one do you want to play there's
like
telestrations categories and just
[ __ ]
fantabulous you know all these games
where they use the same word
the two words and they make one word and
then [ __ ] uh
tan which is like all right you know i
have never seen it but it's like it's
supposed to be a great game and we've
had it for nine years and we've never
even opened it
and then another one i don't know what
it was
and and and they're like how about
telestration
and i'm like dude give me a game where i
don't have to do work i gotta go to draw
and then and then guess and write
i i i'm not going to school anymore i
don't want to do that [ __ ]
don't give me a game where i have to
like [ __ ] all of a sudden be
an artist just let's play a guessing
game
what number am i thinking of seven no
four all right i lose
wanna watch youtubes and um
so we're playing telestries we'll be two
rounds
of course the the girls are like oh we
[ __ ]
thought it was the thing oh you know
after everyone
and the guys are like oh [ __ ] all right
well
oh that was cool no we gotta do another
round because we gotta [ __ ] think
about the thing we're gonna do the thing
he did all right we got a pen and a
[ __ ] ch you cheated and they're gonna
figure out we're like all right we'll
play again i got what other games you
have
and they're like we can play
scattergorge like now let's [ __ ]
stick with illustrations i don't have to
guess 10 of them
and um so we play a few times
i'm being funny you know whatever it's
it's it was actually fun right and then
we played the heads up thing
and uh the one where you go
up and down and [ __ ] and uh
there were act out ones so we got 10 on
that [ __ ]
and then i don't even know how did we
get on this but
kristen was like
i think somebody was like talking about
do you believe in ghosts or some [ __ ]
yes that's what that's how it came up
and i was just like
i know i'm not gonna believe in some
like there's so many like the topic of
like my buddy from ghost hunters like i
asked him once
aaron i asked him once about like do you
believe in ghosts and he was like oh
[ __ ] yeah dude and i was like cool i'm
i'm happy you believe in it
but like until i get some sort of
haunted type [ __ ] happening to me even
remotely
something i can't explain then i'll be
oh wee bae meme right i'll be oh
but until then any
[ __ ] apparition i see
that's a person and i just [ __ ] up
right like there's never been like
there's never even been i thought i
closed that door that's never happened
in my life
why is that dora or what's that shadow
oh
yeah it's a plant that's always how it's
been
you talk to [ __ ] like bobby lee
he would be like and then i saw a face
and it was upside down in the
upstairs of the comedy store and the
lights were on but nobody was in there
and i'm like are you just
lying
and um and
uh and so we [ __ ] we so
so i'm like nah and all the guys are
like nah and all the girls are like
no i totally believe in ghosts and we
were like
how does this matter if you have a dick
or not like that we you believe in it
so my kristen we're i'm like all right
we're talking about ghost is fine at
least we're not playing games
you know great we're not playing games
i'm smooth sailing from here we're back
to talking
we're able to make fun and we're joking
around
kristen is going like this in her head i
realize she's just going like this
you think that's that's it chris
she's not saying this but in her head
she's like you think we're just going to
be talking the rest of the night
wouldn't you like that dude
she says let's do
a ouija board
now the problem with that is viciously
don't
wanna right
and the guys are like what the [ __ ] you
talking about and she's like no
we can i'm like we don't have a ouija
board haha [ __ ] nailed yet and she's
like we can print one out
it's 2021. and i'm like nah
it's not gonna be the same and she puts
it prints it out already by the way
printed it out
i thought she went to go get a drink she
came back with a whole [ __ ] ouija
board with a whole ass ouija board
she made it ah she made it dude and she
had candles
she's like turn out all the lights and i
was like come on dude
this doesn't work it doesn't work
it's a [ __ ] board game there's no
spirits dude
so we're like well we don't have the
moving thing and then and then one of
the girls like you know you can use a
carter
and we were like no you can't because
you can't even use the thing
it doesn't work because it doesn't work
and then dude so we get a quarter and it
nobody can see the lights are on and i'm
doing jokes every time i'm doing jokes
just like it's not the time you know
and i'm like it's a [ __ ] come on if
if we're gonna do this we gotta joke at
least
what do i have to [ __ ] you i gotta
actually believe in it
you're making me believe i don't believe
in it
i gotta act oh oh oh what is the spell
oh you're not pushing it you know what i
mean these [ __ ] these [ __ ]
[ __ ] that do it you watch it on
youtube
are you pushing it you're not pushing it
you swear i'm not putting i'm dude i'm
not pushing it are you gonna push
what's it oh it said howard are you
kidding me
there's a guy howard he died in this
house
no no no it never happened none of it
ever happened
dude and she was like do it and so i did
it with the guys the quarter never moved
how come
how come the quarter never move when the
guys did it and when the girls did it it
spelled [ __ ] edo
ado by the way which is nothing
they were like are you put no are you
three of them three [ __ ] little
fingers uh with the push
pushing a quarter not knowing which one
of those [ __ ] are pushing the
goddamn quarter
but one of them is for sure pushing the
[ __ ] corner
and they're just like you're not you're
not you're not you're not
the person who's even pushing it they
probably don't even know they're doing
it that's how [ __ ] stupid it is
you're not you're not pushing it a oh my
god where's it going
d oh my god you're not pushing it oh
who's
edo
nobody's edo and then the girls
immediately get on their phone 8080
los angeles aldo came up the shoes
is it the shoe store is he alive check
if aldo who owns aldo
is still alive
and then [ __ ] how
how old is edo how old are you
three what is it oh my god are you
pushing it no it's three
then i'm like is he three she's like
wait it could be another number
six he was 36 oh my god google 8036
right now you know what came up a bunch
of japanese [ __ ]
who lived in this house before who lived
in this house before looking at who
lives
dude i if you saw my house go on my
instagram and look at the [ __ ]
background i have the least haunted
house
there is there's like marble and [ __ ]
places
like like nice lamps
there i i the [ __ ] there's never been
a rocking chair in my goddamn house
nobody's ever even worn a flowy dress
and then she's got the nerves these good
the girls got the nerve to be like don't
you got to take it
once when i was in high school somebody
wanted to play [ __ ] frisbee golf and
we were playing and i was laughing he
said you know it's a lot more fun if you
take it seriously
[ __ ] goddamn [ __ ] can i just
do me
dude i gotta do everything your way
mormon's got it right they won't even
let you in the goddamn church if you
don't believe it good
i'm outside
are you mormon no then you can't come to
our wedding oh well [ __ ]
thank you jebediah or whatever the [ __ ]
they're called i don't know
it's crowded anyway we have 19 brothers
so we did the ouija board which is
spelled
w e e
j i e period no matter what
i don't og it's not uh you know
dude the [ __ ] look on my buddy's
girlfriend's face
was just like well
they were like have you ever had
anything that's inexplicable and i was
like
no i have really yeah what is it
well when one time
these like southern men who i know very
well
were like out on a field and they saw
like
all together saw a horse and carriage
like way out on the path and then
they could they were like what the heck
is that and then they went to sleep and
then they woke up
and they went out to look at the path
and there were no tracks
get a new brain
it was people or
they all saw something that wasn't there
cause ghosts are always in a [ __ ]
horse and carriage and [ __ ] you know
with like bonnets on
where's the cool guy ghost is this hacky
a guy has to be hacky some comedian must
do a bit like this
where's the ghost that's like [ __ ]
fonzie hey you'd be like oh [ __ ] i wanna
hang out with that this isn't spooky at
all that's why
because it's not spooky at all
i'm talking about it's always the
creepiest ghosts
because it can't be [ __ ] cool ghost
because it's not creepy dude if that
[ __ ] came out it was like
uh who george clooney
with his [ __ ] lopping ass head just
well hey guys
i know i died but i'm just here to kind
of does anybody need some tips on how to
[ __ ] bag a hot lawyer
do you know what i mean because it's not
creepy you'd be like oh cool
ghost that proves it right there
is anybody in here those [ __ ] things
what was that did you hear that
and then they got the [ __ ] tools all
the tools that measure all the [ __ ]
wow this measures heat in stick figures
and this
is obviously bent neck lady because
it uh
i don't know man i just don't i
i and it's like i know the argument was
like i don't believe it
it's like yeah but you don't believe it
because why you don't believe it cause
you can't see it we can't see air you
still believe in air yeah but there's
science that backs it up show me the
[ __ ] ghosts dude
show me the ghosts um
this is uh and i'm on tick tock and i'm
trying to [ __ ] you know and like dude
every tick tock i i don't watch tech i
don't see any tick tocks my buddy's like
you should go on tick tock it's funny
man there's funny tick tocks
no but let me tell you something dude
every tick tock is
i used to be this way and now i'm
[ __ ] this way and it's like
i don't care oh you use
oh somebody i don't know i've never seen
or met or
even thought of or knew existed used to
be a certain way
and now that person is a different way
oh
well hold the [ __ ] phone dude i love
when people or i don't know our ways or
not ways
god people love to be like check out my
glow up
and dudes do it
the one tick tock of the guy [ __ ] hey
we're partying
you gonna come the guy with the [ __ ]
tongue movement dude that's so gross
that's so [ __ ] gross hey
you guys want to hang
i want to go to a party and the guy the
other guy's in the passenger seat like
hey are you [ __ ] are you a lizard
dude put your tongue in your mouth
put your tongue in your mouth i am
dotchy i am dotchy or whatever the [ __ ]
it is i'm 41 um
how about the papa john's tick tock shut
it down
shut it down now
papa john's made the illest tick tock
alive
shut it down that's it
that's it papa john's started a
tick-tock
where he was facing the other way
swiveled around in his chair and winked
it down
[Music]
shut it the [ __ ] down dude and he
duetted it
with a 21 year old girl shut it down
all right pete tick tock you [ __ ] did
it papa john's
you did it again you
made it said the n-word
fell out of fashion and made it again
dude you're my hero how'd you do it papa
john
and all the while kept
having people know you
as papa john
that's the most dmx [ __ ] i ever heard
he's more dmx than dmx
he winked
anytime
let's find can you find it send it dude
papa john's shut tick-tock
on its [ __ ] ass he kicked the [ __ ]
out of tick-tock
he goes what's tick-tock where the [ __ ]
is tick-tock give me a [ __ ] come here
tick-tock
got it i had to cut to [ __ ] find it
duet with paige m evans
and papa john's what's this papa bless
[ __ ] papa john schnatter
well here we go gonna play this
this [ __ ] shut me down don't
flirt them i'm not going to
ah the ice cold wink dude
don't flirt with him i'm not going to
flirt with him
and he turns around he did before he
winks
wow to wink
like a real [ __ ] is hard and
this
dude is the realest winker alive
i can't [ __ ] believe he did it
don't flirt with him i'm not going to
pause on the face
don't flirt with him why can't i [ __ ]
unbelievable let's get that face let's
pause that face right there
oh almost got it oh we win
i can't get over it that's it he's my
best friend
oh how about the [ __ ] let's turn this
music off this is these
these are the guys who licked her who
show their tongue 900 times in the thing
first of all he's got a [ __ ] bass pro
shop hat on
you know ah
[Music]
just here's what i have to say about
that
and then he just [ __ ] kills it with
the look at this
here we go i'm playing it i can't play
the music because oh
they almost [ __ ] they wouldn't
reverse by mistake
oh god look at look at that the music
pulls up next to us
oh yo we got a party all coming
what
unforgettable are you coming to the
party or no haha
we might just have to the both of dude
why not a good time never hurt nobody
i got a little drink but it's not
bacardi
i bet whoops we went backwards
[ __ ] that's a little awkward
just like both of them but both of them
dudes
hey guys do you i get not knowing what
you're
doing but do you look at each other
hey dog stop putting your tongue out
like that it's like mad
weird what i'm doing it too
no way yeah look what just the [ __ ]
just gross hey guy move on
imagine pulling up to someone dude
that's also the [ __ ] that only works
when you're
in [ __ ] whatever these guys ages are
papa john's took this [ __ ]
and was like nah [ __ ] that y'all
he took back the [ __ ] tongue out lip
uh
i wink papa john's took that
[ __ ] back papa john's made it
and made it again
he reheated the pizza on y'all
[ __ ] unbelievable dude
yo we got a party tonight y'all coming
oh [ __ ] all right now we got but it's
not bacardi
here we go let's watch again yo what
and you are unforgettable ask me
are you coming to the party or not we
might just have to
oh why not a good time never heard
nobody
i got a little drink but it's not
bacardi
we'll see you there right there
he comes back ah tongue out that's a
little awkward
and drives away dude
yeah dude this podcast is the [ __ ]
[ __ ]
man we talk about [ __ ]
god damn i need to [ __ ] i need to
talk to kristen like that tonight dude i
need to get on that tonight man
i need to be like i need to get the
candles on
lights down ouija board
to the side she comes out what's going
on are we trying to summon some
spirits and i just go nah
hahaha
you thought we was going to summon some
spirits nah i got a drink
but it ain't bacardi you know me and
it's la croix uh
you want to get freaky without these
spirits
and she says uh what and i [ __ ] take
a step back whoops that was awkward and
then walked towards to the bedroom
just like
[Laughter]
my mom and dad
pretty [ __ ]
[ __ ] it up because the sound was off
the surprise
yeah love it whoa [ __ ]
previously on tongues out
shout out to bryce parker for [ __ ]
making my year with that [ __ ] dude
that guy's tongue is out so much more
than regular people's
your tongue is [ __ ] seventy percent
of your tongue is out
thirty percent of the time
do you know what i mean on that kid you
know his parents were like dude
what's up man you're gonna have a dry
ass tongue one of these days
70 of his tongue is out 30 of the time
and that's just the [ __ ] facts
man
um all right dude how long has it been
an hour in what
12. cool let's see if i had anything
else to talk about
hey guys what's up uh i had to find this
[ __ ] so i
cut um but i wanted to um
i wanted to uh talk about this here uh
support
this guy i know dave brown and his
family organized
this was organized by ryan hall but uh
it is a gofundme and
if we'll put the link in what the the
video
under under in the youtube video would
that be good and
um yeah
it's our friend and co-worker dave brown
and his wife were going through a very
unexpected and difficult time in their
lives
they've spent the last couple of months
no not knowing what his symptoms were
leading to turns out it's a blood and
bone marrow cancer anyway you can read
all about it it's really
um you know it's hard for
for these people and uh everyone's going
through [ __ ] in life and
i just figured since um
you know um this is personal to me
that i would share it if you guys can
and if you want to
hit up this gofundme um and
help support dave brown and his family
uh
and if you can't you can't but just keep
him in this in your thoughts
um that'd be [ __ ] awesome
uh all right you guys thank you um
that's it for this episode on youtube if
you want to keep watching
the uncut episode go sign up on our
patreon there's also behind the scenes
footage there is also
uh an an extra episode a month uh and
all that is on our patreon
uh it's at uh patreon.comchrisdelia
and you can find it all there but sign
up there's a discord we all chat on
you can pitch segment ideas um and i use
some of them on the show so
yeah you guys uh that's that
congratulations
[Music]
thank you
linochi's talking about i i made 100
bucks i took it out i'm like bro what
are you doing